[Música]
una enorme tugurio sostenido por pilotes
situado en el sur de lagos la capital
económica de nigeria macoco es el mayor
barrio marginal flotante del mundo
grados
alrededor de un cuarto de millón de
personas viven aquí en condiciones de
extrema pobreza pero hoy los niños de la
zona esperan algo donde una joya ha
venido de visita
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a mí me gustó más
tras mes
como ellos precios en un barrio marginal
pero yo
y ha venido a enseñarles a jugar ajedrez
gary está seguir
y estados
unidos
[Aplausos]
son arios leves
cada fin de semana trabajan para mejorar
su rendimiento gracias a una colla un ex
campeón de ajedrez
y
pensé que si podía enseñar a los niños
de los barrios marginales a jugar al
ajedrez la percepción del mundo sobre
ellos cambiaría en lugar de mirarlos
como pobres niños los mirarán como niños
que realmente muestran una alta
capacidad intelectual para algo el
objetivo no es que todos sean campeones
de ajedrez usamos el juego como una
forma de darle una tutoría de darles una
educación
una vez que han aprendido lo básico los
niños juegan entre sí supervisados por
un voluntario esta chica de 15 años le
dice que el ajedrez le cambió la vida
no había oído hablar del ajedrez antes
de que llegara donde una colla me ha
dado más confianza estoy frente a mucha
gente estoy jugando con diferentes tipos
de personas puede hacer que mis sueños
se hagan realidad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
o la bola se vio obligada a abandonar la
escuela por falta de dinero y ha estado
ayudando a su madre a vender jabón y
champú por los canales de la barriada en
lugar de ir a clase
pero hoy vuelve a sacar sus cuadernos un
donante de la organización benéfica que
organiza sus clases de ajedrez se ha
ofrecido a pagar su escolarización
y espero ser doctora en un futuro para
poder ayudar a mucha gente porque
nuestra comunidad mucha gente muere por
culpa del dinero
no tienen dinero así se mueren
en ami y dum otra barriada de lagos es
día de competición esta vez
está
[Música]
comienza el torneo de ajedrez
una vez al mes los niños del barrio se
enfrentan entre sí con un pequeño premio
en efectivo para los mejores
a medida que pasa el día la atención
aumenta
[Música]
mabel ha ganado su cuarto partido
solo tiene 8 años
utilizamos este medio para cultivar su
talento para mostrarles que siempre
habrá una recompensa por el trabajo duro
cuando ganan ganan premios y premios en
efectivo con eso pueden ayudar a sus
familias
entre los niños mayores está michael de
15 años que ha llegado más sano
michael ha ganado una beca para asistir
a un colegio privado y también recibirá
un computador
[Música]
la organización benéfica quiere ahora
expandirse a otros países de áfrica
y provocar un cambio en la vida de los
niños de todo el continente